hi there Steve Kaufman here I want to do
a video here because I've been putting
up these google hangout videos and one
of my viewers said we want to see the
old style video where you talk about
language learning and after this hangout
of business so I'm gonna talk a bit
about phrasal verbs and business English
and other similar subjects before I do
that though I just want to mention that
I'm quite surprised at Google hangout
how unreliable it is we were in the
middle of our hangout and I should
explain I do these hangouts primarily to
explain link to link members and
therefore I like to broadcast them
through YouTube because there are many
people who don't come to the table
source Beach who would like to learn
more about how to get the most out of
link I'm happy to do more of them I'm
happy to do them in different languages
hangouts so let me know I'm quite
responsive to what people want one
person asked me whether I speak Swedish
because I was born in Sweden and I do I
lived in Sweden till I was five I forgot
my Swedish but I learned it back and I
haven't even had a request to do a
hangout in Swedish and if there's
interest I'll do a hangout in Swedish or
in any other language and those of you
that don't want to watch the hangout
videos at my youtube channel you can
just not watch them there identified as
hangout videos and I will certainly
continue to do my regular rants and
today I will be renting again on phrasal
verbs and academic English my view is
that phrasal verbs cannot be taught
academic English cannot be taught
business English cannot be taught morals
cannot be taught what I mean is that the
way to learn these aspects of the
language is the same way as you learn
the language itself in other words
through a lot of listening and reading
and through paying attention noticing
and so how do we notice well if I'm
reading a book
and you know in the case of say Russia
the issues are not phrasal verbs so much
as verbs of motion or case endings so I
underlined while I'm reading I save
these in link I tagged them I review
them you know as a list concentrated
examples of how these things work
obviously with phrasal verbs you can't
rely on any particular you know logic we
were in our hangout we were talking
about phrasal verbs and the example of
invite me over
of course the over there doesn't mean
the same as get over and when we say get
over something hangover after you know
you have too much to drink I mean over
has that sense of like over there or
over it but you really have to learn
these various phrasal verbs by seeing
them off and just as we learn individual
examples of vocabulary often by seeing
them often so again if I save these and
link and I see them highlighted in
yellow the next time they pop up I'm
reminded that I've seen them before I
can review them as I say if I tagged
them the same with say business English
to learn business English you have to
listen to and read a lot of content that
relates to business and you have to save
words and phrases that are useful when
discussing business you have to acquire
that vocabulary the same is true with
with modal verbs so when I have issues
in a language that I'm learning that
present either problems for me in terms
of the way these patterns work then I
make sure I get a concentrated dose of
them in other words the initiative to
learn these things has to come from the
learner I don't think these things it
can be taught if I'm interested in
learning medical terminology I will read
lots of articles that relate to medical
terminology or you know health issues
medicine and I will save key words and
phrases and I will tag them so that I
can review them and that way I noticed
them again
or if I'm reading away from the computer
I underlined so you're constantly
working to help your brain notice these
things while at the same time exposing
yourself to as much of it as possible so
the point I wanted to make in all of
this is while from a marketing point of
view it's great to be able to sell books
and sell courses on business and make
English academic English modal verbs and
these kinds of things but ultimately the
learner has to identify those things
that they find difficult and has to
train themselves to notice these things
now obviously if you have us if we're
talking phrasal verbs or or modal verbs
if you have a little look that stresses
these that has whatever explanation is
there this all may help you to notice so
I'm not saying don't go out and buy
little books to help you but the main
task is for you to start noticing these
things as you're listening and reading
so there you have it my take on phrasal
verbs and the like
and so you'll notice from this by the
way just to comment further on the
discussion I had with many of the Irish
polyglot I have the greatest respect for
him as a person who has promoted
tremendous interest in language learning
and we both agree on that and we also
both agree that people can have
different approaches to language
learning in my case I remain very very
much input based in other words you're
learning from the language the language
is the teacher so you need to get
exposed to that language as much as
possible not to other students learning
the language not the teachers explaining
the language but to the language itself
and you'll know when you want to start
speaking but absorbing the language
through input and developing the ability
to notice that language and exposing
yourself to the language as much as
possible are in my view the keys to
language learning success okay thank you
for listening bye for now